they're said to be a handful of
Democratic senators considering a vote
to acquit we'll see one of those
mentioned frequently West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin imagine he joins us
tonight senator thanks for the time we
know you have to get some dinner so I
want to want to keep you too long but
what did you learn today if anything has
anything today in your QA and you asked
a question today did it change your
opinion on anything well no it just give
us some clarity there's some
discrepancies that came back if you
heard basically the first two or three
days of the prosecution from the house
and in the defense from the president I
think both of them were compelling both
of them were articulated in their job
they did their homework and presented
them well but there were some
contradictions going on and we wanted to
make sure so I think the questions are
being asked is to get clarity to that
tomorrow should help immensely then
we'll see where we go and the witness is
a big thing you know I really believe
that and I think you know that I feel
witnesses are needed and also documents
that are pertaining to the charges
brought against the president because at
one time I heard the president say and I
agreed with him that he said I don't
think I can get a fair trial over on the
house
I need a fair trial on what witnesses
and I think he should get a fair trial
and the Senate is where the trial will
be now you know opening the door to
witnesses obviously opens the door to
Republicans and the Republican side
calling witnesses today you were asked
whether 100 Biden was relevant you said
yes that got pushed back from Chuck
Schumer and a whole bunch of your
Democratic colleagues you still feel
that way
well here's the thing I've said better
but I want to make sure I clarify this
the clarity is is just the Republicans
have a right to call witnesses
it's a Democrats called to witnesses
should Republicans have a right to call
two or four and for whatever they agree
on now what they might not agree on
whether this person is not relevant
because it really is not the person
whether it's the Bynes or somebody else
well you know what my opinion was my
opinion but there should be somebody and
I would think the Chief Justice Roberts
should be that person when there's a
discrepancy
should they be valid to be a witness
because they have pertinent in from
that would be contributing to whether
the president is convicted on the two
articles of impeachment or acquitted
that's all I had said and that's what I
still if you if their vote comes down
and Republicans managed to get the votes
to prevent witnesses could you consider
a vote to acquit in that scenario the
whole thing makes it difficult is so
hard to have a fair trial I've never
I've never been a juror I've never been
called to jury duty in my entire life so
this is something new to me but it's so
fascinating and I take this extremely
serious it's very very serious charges
and it's the thing that does know the
legislature shouldn't want to be setting
for an impeachment of any choice yes you
could consider I have everything open I
have not made my mind up I am impartial
I want to wait until this whole process
is over and I will make the mind up that
you know I'm not where you come from
West Virginia seems to be making its
mind up you know back in 2016 I voted
for President Trump by about 70 percent
and the recent polls that we can find on
this issue of impeaching and removing
the president it's about the same
opposing removing the president about
70% of West Virginians could you
convicted invoke to convict the
president and look at your constituents
and say I understand you have a vote in
nine months but I've determined it's so
egregious I need to kick him out of
office now Brett here's the thing
basically my responsibility I take
serious I think the people that know me
for a long time I've been in West
Virginia for a long time been elected in
many many positions to represent the
great state and they're wonderful people
West Virginia the governor for two terms
and then here for almost 10 years now
they expect me to do what's fair and
what's right and not have to
the home and explain it I've said this
if I can't explain it I sure can't vote
for if it makes sense and I can explain
it than I can that's why I've been
waiting to see all of the evidence I
haven't been quick to judgment anybody
who is prejudge the president one way or
another
no but person it's above the law and
everybody is innocent until proven
guilty and that's the rule of law and
that's what I'm going to say I
understand that once and it's not
finished yet and I understand you have a
couple more days here but Republicans
say one the aid was released flowed out
on top to that time that he got out well
it got out the there was a meeting at
the UN with the president of Ukraine no
announcement was made on investigations
of the Biden's or burries maneuver and
the Ukrainians including the Iranian
president said they didn't feel any
pressure considering those things
understanding the presentations you've
seen so far if you get to Friday and
there are no witnesses considering those
with the stipulations can you vote let
me give you one more one more scenario
Brett is that basically we know that we
the Ukraine is fighting Russian
aggression and that's the main main
purpose for us and they turn our allies
they're fighting Russian aggression you
have a new president has no political
experience whatsoever
coming in that person comes in zalinsky
and basically he's talking to the
superpower of the world the most
powerful person and I'm sure that
basically he's needing this very much in
a very priest of the president 2017-2018
has been very clear gave them lethal
weapons a javelin to protect themselves
that was great I was always for that but
then then this this assertion hasn't
been made so we have to make sure that
we uncover every stone every cover you
cannot be involved we cannot allow
foreign entities to be involved that's
the purpose of who we are as a country
no I get it that's what Democrats are
arguing I'm just saying what I got I've
got to see what actually happened you
know
and can you turn to West Virginians and
say I know all this stuff didn't happen
but because of how the Democrats
presented it we need to kick him out of
office nine months before the election
yeah and here's the other thing has been
brought to my attention - and you're
saying no one should be kicked out of
office unless the charges are absolutely
factual but with that being said should
we just say the same thing is what is
what McConnell had said and Merrick
garland
what's one year so why should we do
anything let me ask you two more quick
things do you have any concerns about
the whistleblower and the contacts with
the House Intelligence Committee Adam
Schiff said again today he doesn't know
who the whistleblower is do you have I
have to believe you know what I try to
trust the people that I work with if
they lied to me once then then shame on
all of us because I'll never believe him
again so if they're saying that they
didn't know I would believe that they're
telling the truth
if they're willing to do it under oath
that even tells me more so you know it
is what it is right now we're and he
said she said who's back and forth what
side are you on my tribe I'm a proud
West Virginia Democrat but I'm more
proud American and I am NOT going to
make a decision I want my present to
succeed and do well but I wanted to live
within the law and they're not above the
law so we all have to make sure if we're
doing everything by the law
I tried to get to to an answer a couple
of times senator we appreciate your time
and once you get some some dinner and
head back in we're thank you very you'll
get an answer pretty quick you all right
tell you that I appreciate it thank you